new details in the death of financier
Jeffrey Epstein on Friday New York
City's medical examiner ruled Epstein's
death a suicide by hanging the 66 year
old was found dead in his Manhattan jail
cell one week ago Epstein who has been
linked to powerful figures and
presidents was scheduled to be tried
next year on sex trafficking charges
involving underage girls Kenneth Craig
is here with more Kenneth good morning
good morning to you Dana
Epstein's lawyers say they are not
satisfied with the medical examiner's
findings and that they're planning to
launch their own investigation this will
likely not put to rest conspiracy
theories that have circulated since
Epstein's body was found one week ago
today Jeffrey Epstein used a bedsheet
attached the top of a bunk bed according
to the New York Times The Times reports
the medical examiner found Epstein
hanged himself with enough force to
break several bones in his neck that
disputes conspiracy theories that the
disgraced financier was murdered to
protect powerful friends and enemies
about whom he may have had incriminating
information New York City chief medical
examiner dr. Barbara Sampson said in a
statement she determined Epstein killed
himself after careful review of all
investigative evidence Epstein was found
unresponsive in his New York jail cell
6:30 a.m. last Saturday where he was
being held pending a new trial on
federal charges of sex trafficking
prosecutors say he sexually abused girls
as young as 14
although guards were supposed to look in
on him every 30 minutes to have been
suspended for allegedly leaving him
unattended that day for three hours
dozens of women over the years have
claimed Epstein forced them to have sex
with him and/or his friends Michele
Licata says she's one of the victims
once something like this happens it
lives on with you forever since Epstein
died several alleged victims have filed
civil suits against his estate the
wealth manager owned a private island in
the Caribbean along with homes in Paris
and New York City some estimates put the
value of what he left behind at hundreds
of millions of dollars
and Epstein's lawyers say they want a
review surveillance video from inside
the jail they say the facility was
operated under quote medieval conditions
still so many questions about how this
was able to happen yeah you know for the
women who just don't get any closure
exactly right now to a lot of suspicions
there Thank You Kenneth